halo hat vollkommen zu sallys welt jetzt
denkt ihr euch wahrscheinlich was machen
die zwei hier in der küche
es wird kein langweiliges bieten sie vor
was haben sie vor
wir stehen hier nicht den parcours in
unserer kirche sein wird in dem chor 6
gesehen im einkaufszentrum in mannheim
uns in den ersten obergeschoss in
unseren stores und restore herzlich
willkommen ja und wir haben seit heute
den dritten tag geöffnet und man muss
sagen dass sally store den haben wir uns
schon seit über einem jahr bleiben da
dran und machen und tun und organisieren
und es war alles etwas anders geplant so
als jetzt ist das kam natürlich viel
dazwischen und wir wollen euch heute
mitnehmen in die kleine zeitreise zurück
an den anfang als wir noch gedacht haben
menschen wir machen hier den store
aufmachen eine fette gleiche rhein ist
für eine gute idee wie zu hause und dann
kam alles anders als geplant
da war es wohl nichts mit der öffnung
und ich steh zwar hier und sagt es ja so
fröhlich aber im also eigentlich macht
mich ziemlich traurig weil wir wirklich
alles super schön organisiert und
vorbereitet hatten und jetzt sozusagen
vieles ausfällt aber dennoch wollen wir
euch zeigen wird dieser shop entstanden
ist ich bin ich glaube ich jetzt schon
mal kurz entschuldigen dafür dass wir
die eröffnung ich angekündigt haben aber
es hat einfach viele gründe wir dürften
zum einen keine menschenmassen hier am
wir müssen einfach
sicherheitsvorkehrungen treffen ja eben
sehen leider alle massen den in den in
die morgen griffen nur 900 leute rein
insgesamt drei bis 4000 leute dann haben
die anderen händler hier bringe nichts
mehr davon denn dass er unverletzt ist
unsolidarisch und gerade zur heutigen
zeit sollte dir zeigen es gibt keine
konkurrenz nur ein wir-gefühl die bisher
das klang und heimlich gemacht ja
natürlich möchte ich euch trotzdem gerne
zeigen wie alles angefangen hat und
deswegen gehen wir jetzt ganz an den
anfang zurück
[Musik]
q wie q 6 sieht dann seid ihr richtig
gelaufen
[Musik]
ja und ja hinter uns seht ihr den
schockierten gerade auch zu denn wir
bauen ja noch 114 meter und per die
fensterfläche laufmeter mit komplett
aufgemacht wird riesengroß
[Musik]
heute war hier pressekonferenz das heißt
heute haben wir eröffnet dass es hier
einen sex shop geben wird und jetzt
zeige ich euch mal wieder laden momentan
noch aussieht ich war vor kurzem schon
da da war da noch die überreste vom
laden sofort drin und heute sind können
und alex schon da seit ein paar tagen
und werkeln schon kommen am netz ich
zeige euch das mal die us-justiz ihr
momentan gerade aus also man kann sich
ein bisschen jazz vorstellen hier vorne
gibt es an der kasse da rechts und links
die regale die ganze fensterfront wird
zugemacht da machen wir dann so led
panels nach außen
dann können nämlich nach außen auch die
videos ausstrahlen und das sieht man
dann aus und von der freßgass' also wenn
man dann wirklich nach oben schaut dann
sieht man bei uns kein schaufenster
sondern eben einen bildschirm und stahl
lassen wir dann eben alles laufen worauf
sie gerade lust haben und hinter mir
kommt die küche hin und das wird die
küche eins zu eins wie bei mir daheim ja
ich glaube das wird ziemlich cool
aber ich kann mir momentan das ist
glaube ich wie in seiner wohnung die man
zur frisch bezieht so bei einer
wohnungsbesichtigung noch nicht
vorstellen wie groß ist alles wird also
ja ich bin nur gespannt habe ich das
wird schön jetzt wird gebaut
[Musik]
unser shop so langsam wird er jetzt voll
fiel schon eingeräumt also werden die
ganze koch blogger ware die ganze gv
waren die ganze sally ware kitchenaid
kenwood was habe ich noch de cuba kann
man alles schon versäumt was wir jetzt
noch machen als das lager ist schon voll
die regale an der wand sind schon voll
was wir hier machen
ich habe mir vorgestellt dass er immer
so thementische haben und jetzt fangen
wir an mit dem ersten thementisch das
ist der thematische ursache das heißt
alles was rosa ist kommt hier auf den
tisch dann machen wir einen carbon black
tisch dann machen wir einen torten von
danz modellierte lauter thementische
dass man einfach so die vielfalt sieht
das passt zueinander und schaffen so
kleine welten im installiert ok also
gusseisen teekanne
schellnhuber
[Musik]
wir haben das ist der kassenbereich und
wie es halt gerade überall ist aufgrund
der verordnungen müssen wir so ein spuk
schutz machen und zwar das wie so eine
schutzwand dass er spricht dass man
keine tröpfcheninfektion bekommt dass
der spuk schutz hatte könne aber schon
seit jahren
der trägt ist seit jahren schon juni
oder du musst schauen so einen spruch
schutz tragen aber schon seit längerer
zeit das waren schon immer gesetzt juni
muss man hier übrigens auch noch ein
dings und dach drüber machen
ja genau also nach müsse man noch machen
wie man gespannt wie es nachher aussieht
[Musik]
hier drin haben wir was ganz ganz
besonderes und zwar es ist ein giant
step mixa und dieses ding was hier drin
ist das gibt es normalerweise nur auf
ganz international ganz großen messen
und das ist jetzt in mannheims
allererste mal und er wird auch in
mannheim stehen bleiben daher ich werde
jetzt auspacken und schaut euch das
dieses riesen ding mal anpacken was man
aus daniel bis gespannt was drin ist
okay los
das wird wahrscheinlich größe
bienenstich wenn ich jemals in meinem
leben gebacken habe voran sind
[Musik]
alle herzlich willkommen ist alice shop
in mannheim
ich habe mich wie alice im wunderland
eingefordert und wuchs in der
küchenmaschine gefällt es mir gut da
gehe ich wieder rein
hallo heute geht es weiter bei uns hier
im shop
jetzt bin ich endlich da rein
los geht's
[Musik]
ja was wir jetzt gerade machen ist
20.000 artikeln zu etikettieren sommer
dann nämlich unseren bestand wissen was
da ist und dann wird alles noch mal
fertig gestellt dauert jetzt schon eine
weile als ein bisschen schon seit
starken dran und es dauert glaube ich
noch ein paar tage
du hilfst mir charts und sind noch
schneller
[Musik]
also erstmal klar erstmal alles
gewaschen
das nimmt ja schon viel zeit in anspruch
alles gewaschen abgetrocknet und hier
kann ich dann meinen vorrat rein machen
wenn ich hier dann koche und backe habe
ich immer wasser mail usw
aber wir müssen noch einkaufen ja aber
ich habe zumindest schon mal zu den
platz blockiert und reserviert und habe
jetzt gedacht hier passen ja ganz gut
weil das ist ja so ein toller
organisations schrank hat mir hier
praktisch so ein drittel des schrank
inhalts und hier so die restlichen zwei
drittel und hab ich gedacht mathematik
die metalldosen hier rein und hier noch
meine vorratsdosen und dann noch die
vorräte ja das sieht gut aus
und ansonsten habe ich mir überlegt dass
wir jetzt die küche noch mit den
pastellfarben einrichten weil mir ist
gerade so nach passt also im august
september kann man dann wieder sein geld
machen
ja ich habe hier auch schon angefangen
einzurichten also auch hier in den
schubladen jetzt schon ganz gut sortiert
sie sind auch die fernbedienungen für
für die küche
[Musik]
dekoriert grad hier die messe box
unserer kunden glas darüber dass mister
eingreifen kann sind saumäßig scharf und
wenn wir uns zusammen haben mir wirklich
coole sachen gemacht eingelagert und und
brettern zusammen gesägt und geschliffen
und das ist richtig cool aus perfekt
perfekt hier kann nichts passieren
so jetzt brauchen wir ein starkes der
mir das glas und ja das ist richtig cool
aus war richtig cool
also wird da jetzt keine lust habe auf
schneiden weiß ich auch nicht
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kummer also ich finde es falsch nach
ganz einfach wenn es regal so vor dir
steht dann erst heißt es für mich mit
den laden reinkommen stoppen ist für
mich wie eine mauer
wenn es etwas länger hast wenn du das
länglich hast dann zeigt die flucht nach
vorne was ich meine psychologie ich
suche auch oft ein fluchtweg fertig wird
so mache und die andere verteile einfach
das ist halt nicht so ein system ergibt
sondern schön verteilt ganz einfach
schön grün die decke grün alles grün
das erhält meine stimmung wenn ich hier
reinkommen beispiel fragt das ohne sie
zu fragen mich immer anderer meinung ist
die logische mal anderer meinung
warum nämlich geheiratet hast das frage
ich mich auch schaffen alle szenarien
durch
[Gelächter]
du bist verrückt
fangen wir an den rücken du hast dann
macht ihr wollt ich gehe in die küche
das finde ich wie ich gerade geschirr
spülen
ich finde auf dem bild gucke ich wie
ella kann das dein service recht stolz
darauf spielen zu dürfen und war immer
so abend kettchen getragen
[Musik]
ja und jetzt hängen wir hier noch alles
auf alex und kündigt die machen hier
gerade die tollen bilderrahmen sarah und
selber kleben die bilder drauf haben wir
leider gomorra die falsch gestellt da
sie mit gas gestellt das muss ich jetzt
sage und die reflektieren also dürfen
alle wieder runter hängen und ohne
filter glasbau aufhängen aber ihr macht
das toll da noch unserer
willkommensschild kommt dann direkt an
den eingang und ein danke für deinen
besuch schiffs wenn man den laden findet
ja ich meine hier kommen wir mit
sicherheit auch menschen vorbei die uns
nicht kennen und wenn da halten unsere
sallis logo draußen ist dann weiß man
vielleicht nicht was es hier sein soll
und deswegen haben wir gedacht machen
wir so ein begrüßungsschild ich glaub so
mit dem ausbau starb und mehr sieht man
gleich mensch die frau die backt die
packt und sie kocht herzlich willkommen
ich find's vollkommen
hallo kann ich hier schon einkaufen nein
wir haben noch geschlossen ok ich komm
trotzdem das ist glaube ich jetzt der
traum von allen ich geht's einfach im
laden shoppen für meine küche ja aus
rolf starb
wo große auswahl starb hier große masse
was brauche ich noch als pioniere
großeinkauf
jetzt noch küchenhelfer ein
flaschenöffner murat sagte sowas wäre
unnötig aber ganz ehrlich im
flaschenöffner braucht man transformer
habe ich schon reiben knoblauchpresse
habe ich küchenmaschine habe ich und
einen dosenöffner kommen
ganz ehrlich hier kann man seinen ganzen
hausstand fühlen aber ich finde es
wichtig weil alle dinge die man in der
küche haben sollte findet ihr auch hier
nix halbes fleischklopfer teigs aber ja
okay und dann noch die breite palette
gott ich stand halt noch nie auf meiner
küche bühne und habe noch nie hier
gesungen ich habe lampenfieber
ich kann mich so vielleicht später ok
hatte ja bereits festhalten
[Gelächter]
die pflegemutter
[Musik]
kommt er auf
und jetzt können wir sagen malen so
ursprünglich wollte immer die zebra ich
überall an die wand hin machen aber wir
haben keine wandflächen mehr und
deswegen um alle täglich auf dem boden
und man kann sie auch hier holen die
teppich man kann live anschauen ich habe
immer schon ein cooles video darüber
gemacht schaut mal hier wo rad und
teppiche auf meiner tour durch die
türkei und jetzt soll ich einfach ins
aus rollen so richtig cool und die
tische drüber und es geht richtig genial
aus kam jemand helfen beim fisch darüber
schieben
[Musik]
ja
mein auge geht nicht mehr auf mein auge
okay die eine fotografiert der
anna-kirche egal egal es ist etwa 22.30
wir sind leider noch nicht fertig werden
sagt etikettieren sommermorgen weiter
wir gucken jetzt einfach danke wir
gucken jetzt einfach dass der
verkaufsraum hier schön wird das alles
im preis hat und ich trockne geschäft
läuft bei mir
das riecht immer noch linsensuppe
deswegen kommt es nicht nur schön
[Musik]
der gerät wird nie müde der gerät
schlechter ein
der gerät ist vor dem chef im geschäft
und der gerät arbeitet schweiß frei und
der gerät ist hat bild falsch rum
aufgeklebt legeres tauscht
[Musik]
die letzten drei vier tage
wir haben hier etikettiert zigtausend
artikeln
wir haben ich hab's lager gemacht mit
der eiligen volkan komplett also alles
lager wir haben die tische dekoriert mit
selma und jesse jasmin julia haben wahre
eingeräumt etikettiert meine cousine
namen war noch da jörg hat mitgeholfen
sarah samira ali murad der rabbi kam
dennis barth i o mein gott ich hoffe ich
habe keinen vergessen habe ich hier mal
vergessen
jedenfalls allen ganz viel danke alex
gurney mein gott alex im juni haben wir
von anfang an ganz alleine gearbeitet
weil wir einfach viel zu tun hatten und
jetzt guckt euch an es ist vollendet j
hier noch die technik aufgebaut sie am
markt hat bis spätabends die ganzen
banner gemacht der daniel hat alles
verliert und ich denke mir geradezu oh
mein gott wir haben wir das alles
geschafft irgendwie ist hier so eine
wohnung entstanden so eine wohnung die
aussieht wie unser haus uns alle unser
ganzer shop ist hier die ganze ware ist
hier und wir haben es geschafft morgen
des samstag morgen werden wir eröffnen
morgen früh
das heißt wir machen morgen früh doch
sauber es wird gesaugt ist wird geputzt
wir werden kasse lernen und wir werden
alles lernen und dann machen wir einfach
den laden auf aber jetzt wirst du was
ich kann nicht mehr ich gehe ins bett
oder ich schlaf einfach hier
oder ich bin plötzlich weiß ich glaube
ich ins bett denn ich bin kaputt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt ist es soweit der shop ist
eröffnet und momentan natürlich ziemlich
blöd überall massiv licht aber ist
leider so klar der schutz geht vor und
die gesetze und vorschriften natürlich
auch ich stehe dir macht geht's ab weil
ich moderiere weil ich jetzt keine
menschen treffe und weil los und ich
sozusagen in einem team sind jedoch
strikte bei der maske nutzer in form
ich glaube ich muss dazu sagen weil
sonst weder geschimpft wird
ich gebe euch jetzt am besten einfach
kurz eine job tour für alle die
vielleicht nicht kommen können oder
einfach sich überlegt haben
später mal irgendwann vorbei zu schauen
oder eben die eben gar nicht herkommen
ich zeige euch kürzlich im shop zeigt
euch wie wir alles eingerichtet haben
und ich denke wir fangen direkt am
eingang
ja hier so unser eingangsbereichs
natürlich die jugendgruppen kitchenaid
ich glaube da kommen sowieso ganz viele
und bestaunen die und im prinzip habt
ihr hier dann rechts gleich so unsere
kicker ecke das sieht man die ganzen
schönen farben und hier kann man alles
vor ort einstellen und damit ganz
gemütlich nach hause geliefert wir haben
hat auch kein lager hier zwingen kann
man eben fast gar nichts lagern und
haben hier alles auf der verkaufsfläche
und dann habe ich thementische gemacht
und ich zeige ich euch mal okay als ich
hier am anfang natürlich einen schönen
rose tisch alles was das herz begehrt
weiter hinten habe ich zum beispiel noch
einen schwarzen tisch oder einen
gusseisen tisch ich habe auch einen
basteltisch vereinfacht das ganze passt
ein sortiment drauf ist hier im vorderen
bereich gibt es auch noch einen
praktisch also alles was man zum bug
prozess braucht wie ein backblech kringe
back rahmen ein paar tortenring paletten
oder eben auch andere backformen wie tat
formen weiter hinten habe ich dann
sozusagen den deko bereich mit aus holz
stoff aus hall matte mit den ganzen deko
elementen spritzbeutel zum beispiel eben
auch und 1 hinten dran ist dann
sozusagen
lebensmittel ecke da gibt es alle torten
zubehörteile wie zum beispiel
lebensmittelfarben ich habe back
transfer vanille extrakt die
verschiedenen aromen aber auch von dort
und lebensmittelfarbe an der wand haben
wir sozusagen die komplette bandbreite
an bug artikel und weiterhin und geht es
dann schon zum bereich kochen muss eben
koch werkzeug gibt aus silikon oder eben
auch töpfe und pfannen auf der linken
seite aber dann wie gesagt gusseisen im
mai und das ist sozusagen der bereich
kochen und da sind auch die kochbücher
rechts und er so die backbücher und hier
immer noch im zweiten bereich für
küchenmaschinen und zwar die kenwood
stationen und wir uns da dabei gedacht
dass wir so eine art vergleicht auch
machen das heißt ihr könnt ihr auch
küchenmaschinen vergleichen
seht eben auch was gute qualität
bedeutet und wie wird man natürlich auch
super beraten
das haben wir natürlich auch wieder in
zusammenarbeiten und daniel gemacht
ranshofen kennt ihr wahrscheinlich
strasshof entkommen
daniel begleitet uns ja auch schon seit
fünf sechs jahren mit auf messen und im
sommer gesagt mehr anschlüssen ist man
natürlich auch hier anbieten und habe
mir die tische eben auch bestückt so
kann man die küchenmaschine mal anfassen
mal ausprobieren der elemente in die
hand nehmen sich selbst anschauen und
einfach schaue was eben am besten zu
einem passt
woran ist gerade megawatt aber egal der
spaß der hat einfach spaß hier ja also
was sie hier auch haben sind die bosch
küchengeräte sowie bei mir zu hause wenn
wir im allgemeinen versucht das hier so
nachzustellen wie es bei uns zu hause
ist das heißt wenn man hier in der küche
steht sieht wirklich aus wie man daheim
deswegen trage ich natürlich auch immer
meine crocs guck ich komme hierher wagen
sich immer klar hausschuhe an das ist
schon mal pflicht
ihr könnt gerne auch mit angst schon
kommt das ist aber nicht also hier im
hintergrund haben wir die holzwand die
wir auch zu hause haben und eben auch
alle geräte weil ich ganz oft unter den
videos in kommentaren im nachrichten
gefragt werde was kann denn der backofen
serie a 8 wie stelle ich die dämpfung
zum einen was kann ich denn alles mit
der wako platte machen und so weiter
haben uns gedacht willst du was wir
packen alles auch hier mit in den shop
rein
wir verkaufen die geräte hier nicht die
gibt es einen praktischen küche
fachhandel und hier arbeiten wir aber
mit der claudia zusammenbau der frei
aushandeln
die haben auch eine tolle beratung ist
ja auch unsere küche geplant und mit ist
alles wunderbar umgesetzt eben auch wie
bei uns zu hause und da gibt es eben die
bausch küchengeräte und es steht dann
auch immer schön dran wir haben so eine
so kleine schilder gemacht vorne dran
da steht dann dran welcher backofen
mikrowelle hart welche eine dampf
funktion hat und ebenso die spezifischen
einstellung und dem man da so machen
kann und der kammer herkommen das war
kurz ausprobieren sich durch klicken
hier die kühlschränke auch anschauen
also wenn ihr hier auch vorbei kommt
könnt ihr euch gern mal die küche
anschauen im gesamten haus ja könnt mal
schauen wie es ist so in das die kirche
verstehen ich habe neulich mit der er
telefoniert als ich hier war und habe
videotelefon gemacht und habe mich in
die küche extra gestellt vor dem
backofen und hat sagte er mama du bist
doch zu hause aber ich war eben in der
küche da warst du nicht wo bis zu jetzt
ich bin da gehören sie nein mama aber du
bist doch in der küche nicht nee ich bin
den mannheim und wird es gar nicht
verstanden weil die küche hier einfach
genauso aussieht
das war ziemlich cool ich wollte sie
nicht veräppeln ich habe
ein bisschen
[Musik]
das war's jetzt im prinzip also der shop
hat eröffnet wir haben im prinzip vor
drei tagen still und heimlich geöffnet
mit uns auch wirklich super leute wollen
ja die große eröffnung machen und
bescheid sagen aber das problem ist zum
einen dass wir es nicht durften das
heißt das projekt zu sehen darf momentan
maximal nur acht bis 900 menschen rein
lassen und wenn jetzt alle zu uns
stimmen weil ich verkünde dass wir offen
haben sind die anderen shops alle leer
das wollen wir natürlich nicht denn wer
fühlen alle miteinander wir halten alle
zusammen und ich möchte natürlich auch
wir auch den anderen stores hätten gut
geben ohne gibt es auch richtig genial
in ein tollhaus als auch wenn er zu uns
kommt
wenn ihr sagt hey ich komme jetzt nur
wegen der zelle hierher dann besucht
bitte auch die anderen stores denn das
sind wirklich teilweise auch viele
familienunternehmen und einfach schöne
kleine betriebe die es hier gibt es gibt
immer was tolles neues zu entdecken und
es sind auch viele shops die es woanders
gar nicht gibt in der unterstützten
verhandeln was ganz ganz wichtig ist
habe ich ja vorschlag auch schon immer
gesagt habt unterstützt die innenstädte
was ganz ganz wichtiges unter
normalerweise die zahlen werden sind
hart momentan
normalerweise bieten wir was zu kochen
und zu essen und zu trinken kann
kostenlos im momentan leide ich machen
wir haben über masken pflicht ist alles
in ordnung wir tun alles ist so schnell
vorbeigeht
wir hoffen dass es so schnell weg ist
wie es gekommen ist und freuen uns auf
euch den mal ein etwas kleines positives
hatte es wir hatten jetzt praktisch die
zeit so den letzten zwei drei wochen uns
ein zu arbeiten wenn man auch immer als
team hier mit dabei das heißt wenn noch
mehr arbeitsplätze geschaffen und wir
hatten jetzt einfach die letzten tage
zeit und müssen langsam alles angehen
sondern
1 1 zu arbeiten aber natürlich fehlt mir
einfach so dieses gefühl der großen
eröffnung und ich hoffe und ich weiß
nicht ob es jetzt so ein verträumter
mädchen gedanke ist aber ich hoffe dass
wir auf jeden fall die eröffnung als
unsere marose feier nachholen
dann koche ich für euch back für euch
gibt getränke wir machen kinderschminke
wir holen hoffen sich alles nach und ich
hoffe einfach jetzt auf euer verständnis
auch dass ihr draußen vielleicht warten
müsst in der warteschlange mit abstand
und wer einfach hygienevorschriften die
wir einhalten
ich habe hätten spruch ja ihr seid uns
mit abstand liebsten gästen ja ja ja
also vielen dank fürs zuschauen und ich
denke mal ein neues kapitel in der
gemeinde und guckt mich er helfen kann
ja ruhig aber eben voll quatsch okay ich
war ja ich habe noch was das sagen aber
dafür kann ein stück weg so anfangen als
dass wir im monat oder her schicken
denn wenn ich meine was meine ruhe
braucht beim drehen und beim filmen dann
sage ich einfach morath mannheim braucht
dich und schicke ich ihn einfach her
aber wie gesagt wir sind auch regelmäßig
da und ich freue mich auf euch
und willkommen im neuen kapitel ins
alice welt
[Musik]